die kommunikation ist chaotisch noch
gesundheitsminister sparen erklärte vor
zweieinhalb wochen die epidemische lage
sei ende november beendet bayerns
ministerpräsident müller findet das
völlig absurd nun wollen sich bund und
länder in der nächsten woche treffen
ganz schön spät für einen notfall
wolfgang kubicki ist bei uns fdp
stellvertretender parteichef dieser
partei herr kubicki die notlage
abzuschaffen in höchster not ist das
noch politik oder ist es ideologie
jetzt zunächst einmal läuft die
epidemische notlage nationaler tragweite
am 25.11 automatisch aus und ich habe
bisher kein entwurf der regierung
gesehen oder der cdu/csu-fraktion der
das verlängern will das finde ich
ziemlich komisch dass jetzt ein appell
an die noch nicht bestehende regierung
gerichtet wird oder nicht noch nicht
bestehende koalitionsfraktionen dass sie
jetzt das regeln sollen was die union
bisher versäumt hat wir wollen jetzt und
dass ich sie hätten es gerne verlängert
wollen sie aber nicht sagen nein weil da
viele regelungen denen sind die erste
mir persönlich gefallen von denen
gerichte erklärt habe dass ich rechts
und verfassungswidrig sind und als
parlamentarier kann ich daran nicht
mitwirken wir haben jetzt als parlament
anders als die ministerpräsident
konferenz bei dem er gar nicht weiß wie
sie zu bestimmten ergebnis gekommen ist
haben wir als parlament jetzt ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren eingeleitet mit
einem ersten entwurf der montag eine
anhörung ist und wie das im parlament so
ist werde selbstverständlich die
ergebnisse der anhörung darin einfließen
wird es an vernünftigen eingesetzt ein
vernünftiges gesetz geben was eine
parlamentarische mehrheit das parlament
davon gehe ich aus sind die drei
koalition kommt fünf den
koalitionsfraktionen haben einmal mehr
den haben alle mehr dem deutschen
bundeswehr uni werden sind zwei weiter
umsetzen wir wollen allerdings auch dass
die union sich weiter daran beteiligt
denn noch einmal zu glauben man kann mit
isolierten maßnahmen auch der
santos an eine andere punkte seien wir
jetzt das halte ich für ziemlich komisch
denn die situation die wir jetzt aber
momentan mit 50.000 infektionen am tag
und jetzt auch wieder verlaufenden
intensivstation die geschehen ja unter
dem aktuellen regime und deshalb ist die
überlegung man muss das einfach nur so
fortsetzen und ziemlich schlicht
interessante nochmal die nachfrage es
gibt 18 maßnahmen jetzt sie wollen die
verkürzen auf insgesamt sechs warum
überlassen sie eigentlich den
bundesländern nicht wie bisher dass sie
auch kontakt beschränkungen
schulschließungen im schlimmsten fall
auch lokale lockdown verhängen können
warum wollen sie das nicht nur weil
diese information zu treffen ist die
länder können selbstverständlich eine
schule schließen die gesundheitsbehörde
was sie immer schon konnte wenn dort ein
hotspot ist der ob wir überhaupt 28 hsg
nicht was nicht mehr gewollt ist unser
kern ja auch die unionsfraktionen ist
ein flächendeckender lockdown das
schließen von ganzen branchen weil die
evidenz einer solchen maßnahme bisher
nicht nachgewiesen ist und ohne evidenz
ist das aus meiner sicht schlicht
ergreifend rechtswidrig was wir nicht
wollen sind ausgangssperren die jungs
von mehreren gerichten und jeweils in
zweifel gezogen worden sind was wir auf
jeden fall wollen ist eine verstärkte
testung die wegnahme der kostenlosen
test und mitte oktober einreise
kardinalfehler ok und was wir auf jeden
fall wenn es ein monitoring bisher
wissen wir nicht welche maßnahme welche
wirkung hat und rechtsstaat jedenfalls
darf man grundrechts beeinträchtige
maßnahmen nur machen wenn man erstens
weiß dass die wirkung und zweitens die
verhältnismäßigkeit gehört ist so jetzt
sind wir bei der argumentation der fdp
und schalten nach dresden da sitzt der
ministerpräsident des freistaates
sachsen einen guten abend herr
kretschmar nach dresden es war
ursprünglich entspannt idee die notlage
zu beenden weil vier von fünf
erwachsenen geimpft sein wie groß ist
der schaden aus ihrer sicht und was
sagen sie zu den argumenten von wolfgang
kubicki ja der bundesminister hat
nachvollzogen was die neue koalition die
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag erklärt
hat als gmd und das ende der
pandemischen lage aber es ist ja ganz
erkennbar wir haben überhaupt kein ende
der pandemischen lage im gegenteil ich
glaube dass diese vierte welle die jetzt
kommt alles in den schatten stellt was
wir erlebt haben
das ist eine dramatisches aufbäumen der
infektionszahlen sie habe selbst gesagt
zahlen wie wir sie bisher nie erlebt
haben die krankenhäuser jetzt schon an
einer belastungsgrenze und deswegen ist
es natürlich absolut fahrlässig jetzt
maßnahmen aus dem instrumentenkasten
herauszunehmen niemand verhängte
ausgangssperre oder andere maßnahmen es
ist notwendig dass das mildeste mittel
verwendet wird dafür haben wir gerichte
die haben in der vergangenheit auch
entschieden wenn man diese vernünftige
abwägung nicht getroffen hat aber noch
einmal man kann nicht politisch
entscheidend was ein virus tut oder
nicht sondern wir brauchen jetzt die
erfahrung auch der vergangenen jahre und
monate wir sehen dass wir erstens robert
koch institut heute gesagt hat diese
leute diese wissenschaftler die
mediziner brauchen jetzt politischen
rückenhalt menschen die die dinge auch
aussprechen die in den rücken stärken
das ist eine wirklich dramatische
situation auf die wir uns zu bewegen und
deswegen stehen wir auch bereit wir
handeln auch im rahmen des geltenden
rechts aber wir sehen eben ab 25
november wird einiges nicht mehr möglich
sein und das halten wir für einen fehler
bei uns ist annika klaffki frau kraft
die sie sind jura professorin an der
universität in jena und haben schon
2016 ihre promotion zum thema pandemien
geschrieben wann ist eine und das
scheint ja eine zentrale frage zu sein
wann ist eine massnahme verhältnismässig
woran
orientieren muss sich juristen da das
ist so pauschal kann man das nicht
beantworten sondern es kommt darauf an
ob die maßnahme für ein legitimes ziel
geeignet ist ob sie dafür das mildeste
unter den gleich geeigneten mitteln ist
und ob das bei abwägung der sich
gegenüberstehenden gütern angemessen ist
hier ist das ziel ganz klar zu
verhindern dass die infektion sich
weiter verbreiten also schutz von
körperlicher unversehrtheit und leben
der bevölkerung und in dem fall von coop
19 natürlich auch der schutz des
gesundheitswesens als solche weil wir
eben gehört haben die intensivstationen
ja nach und nach voll laufen und ist
dieses neue gesetz das was wir von ihm
wissen besser als das alte
das würde ich so nicht sehen nein also
es wie schon gesagt wo das verkürzt eben
den maßnahmenkatalog erheblich zum teil
kann man dafür sicherlich gründe finden
dass man einige maßnahmen rausgenommen
hat ob man das so rigoros
zusammenstreichen muss wie das jetzt
gemacht wurde halte ich für schwierig wo
wir instanzen von
50.000 haben was ich vor allem
kritisieren ist das nach wie vor die
maßnahmen so völlig unklar sind im
moment ist ja das konzept wir setzen
alles auf 2g 3g wenn sie aber jetzt in
dieses noch in diesem neuen
gesetzentwurf gucken das steht überhaupt
nichts drin zu was heißt eigentlich
zweig was heißt eigentlich 3g was soll
den gelten kann man zweig auch einführen
für supermärkte und arztpraxen apotheken
das würde ja bedeuten ungeimpfte können
sich gar nicht mehr versorgen was geht
eigentlich für kinder von 12 bis 17
jahren da hat er die ständige
impfkommission gesagt die sollen bitte
ausgenommen werden ist nicht geregelt
man weiß auch gar nicht was geht
eigentlich für private feiern was soll
an weihnachten gelten ist das eine
veranstaltung im sinne des gesetzes oder
nicht all das wird jetzt auf die länder
abgewälzt die müssen es dann irgendwie
aufwändig in ihren verordnungs texten
regeln die verordnung texte werden
dadurch unheimlich lang die müssen alle
vier wochen erneuert werden die bürger
haben überhaupt keine chance das
irgendwie noch zu rezipieren diese ganze
flut an regelung es wäre viel besser das
jetzt auf bundesebene zu machen man wäre
auch demokratisch legitimiert dazu als
parlament auf landesebene können ja
immer nur die exekutiven handelns
insofern ich halte das nicht für ein
gutes gesetz markus söder hat heute zwei
gebe deutschlandweit gefordert ist das
etwas was sie juristisch für legitim
halten würden in der jetzigen situation
ob man das einzel ist eine politische
frage und hängt natürlich auch von der
virologischen faktenlage als ich als
jurist und natürlich nicht voll
beurteilen kann ich halte das für
juristisch zulässig dass einzuführen
wenn man es einführt dann muss man es
klare regeln und klar hineinschreiben
das meint man damit welche ausnahmen
vorgesehen werden wo darf es gelten wo
gilt es nicht gibt es übergangsfristen
für uns all diese fragen all diese
fragen wir sind dabei ulrich reitz
politische fragen klären zu müssen chef
kommentator von focus sie haben bereits
geschrieben wo sind merkel wo ist scholz
wo ist merken wo es scholz korrekter
weise heute hat ist eine rede des
zukünftigen bundeskanzlers im parlament
gegeben gehen wir mal davon aus sind wir
jetzt wieder regiert und wenn ja von wem
was wäre ihre
bedeutung der chef der
parlamentarier der rechtsstaatspartei
fdp buschmann hat heute oder der wie
gesagt von merkel möge sich zurückhalten
weil sie seien nur geschäftsführend im
amt
wer mit einer juristin am tisch und
einen volljuristen auch noch hier sitzen
und § 69 im grundgesetz steht ja drin
was das ist eine geschäftsführende
regierung nämlich eine die voll
geschäftsfähig ist die ist sogar
verpflichtet so steht es in absatz 3
drin die ist sogar verpflichtet ihren
job zu machen denn auf den den auftrag
dazu hat sie gekriegt frau merkel vom
bundespräsidenten persönlich und
deswegen habe ich mich heute schon
gewundert dass frau merkel nicht geredet
hat es gibt politische gründe dafür sie
ist nämlich anderer meinung als die
ampel koalition und anderer meinung als
herr scholz was die fortführung der
pandemischen lage anbelangt sie wäre
nämlich dafür gewesen und insofern hat
sie ist richtigerweise für blöd gefunden
sich im widerspruch und zum noch nicht
berufen oder noch nicht gewählten neuen
bundeskanzler zu begeben das macht man
nicht insofern hat sie hat sie nicht
geredet aber sie könnte sie ist voll
geschäftsfähig und voll regierungsfähig
gar keine frage olaf scholz mehr auf
herrn kubicki gehört als auf herrn
lauterbach
ist es nicht heute im bundestag war hier
und jetzt sogar eingesetzt war ja ganz
witzigerweise hat ja im
bundestag
ein kollege von herrn kubicki gesagt na
ja ein gesetz das von herrn kubicki und
herrn lauterbach unterschrieben wird das
muss ja wohl ganz okay sagen weil die
zwei sich natürlich ständig beiden so
auf der anderen seite base ganz kurz
erklären darf die fdp versteht sich als
rechtsstaatspartei
und als rechtsstaatspartei gibt es gute
gründe das zu beschließen was man heute
gemacht hat nämlich wegen der
gewaltenteilung dass die das nicht mehr
eine bundesregierung sozusagen im
alleingang die exekutive regiert sondern
dass das parlament geht und das ist eine
klare ordnung da ist das kann man
verstehen auch nachvollziehen aber man
darf es nicht verwechseln mit dem schutz
der bevölkerung
der schutz der bevölkerung ist also
argument nachgeliefert worden der ansatz
war eigentlich ganz anders ist das ja
auch kein zufall dass die fdp-leute
unter fd leute sich gerufen haben nach
einem freedom day einen tag der freiheit
und natürlich ist die fdp das team
freiheit und nicht das team vorsicht
wenn ich also ein bisschen forscher als
sagen darf das team vorsichtig auch sehr
erfolgreich wir in bayern sachsen sehen
können ich weiß nicht was mich ärgert
ist wir hätten die diskussion geht sie
zurück wenn in bayern und sachsen mehr
geimpft worden wäre beispielsweise
bieten schließlich standen oder oder in
bremen hätten wir das problem überhaupt
gar nicht und die tatsache dass also wir
mit dem free und bekommen dass wir
endlich sommer stein 2 die einführen
sollen in dem glauben in sachsen würden
instanzen sinken das ist intellektuell
wirklich erbärmlich da ist natürlich
sofort der bei bei ihnen herr
kretschmann was sagen sie zu diesem
argument und warum ist es nicht gelungen
den sachsen die bedeutung des impfens
ans herz zu legen und in den oberarm das
was wir gerade gehört haben von kubicki
teil des problems ist und ich sag nur
hochmut kommt vor dem fall keine region
in der bundesrepublik deutschland hat
bei der jetzigen dynamik eine chance wo
es dann im kommenden jahr an zu kommen
es ist viel zu schnell das ist viel zu
viel wir müssen alle etwas tun und die
frage die man sich stellen muss ist in
der tat genau die was ist notwendig um
diese welle zu brechen um diese dynamik
zu reduzieren und das muss uns leiten
nicht was wir uns mal überlegt haben was
man die opposition sich überlegt hat was
man jetzt aus schleswig-holstein heraus
sieht und auf andere zeigt es gibt
gründe warum die menschen sich nicht
impfen lassen haben es gibt regionen in
deutschland es gibt regionen in europa
in der welt wo das unterschiedlich ist
wir müssen das als fakt jetzt erst
einmal nehmen wir sind hier vor der zeit
aber die anderen kommen nach und
deswegen ist zweig eine variante die
wird nicht reichen wir müssen weitere
instrumente dazu setzen und es braucht
es kluge reden darüber wie das geht die
bundesregierung die geschäftsführende
bundesregierung handelt der
bundesminister hat jetzt die bürger test
wieder angewiesen und dafür brauchte er
die zustimmung auch des
bundesfinanzministers es hat eine weile
gedauert ab ende dieser woche oder
anfang nächster woche geht es los dann
brauchen wir die möglichkeit das in der
tat die unternehmen ihre beschäftigten
abfragen können wer ist kämpft wäre es
nicht geimpft dass man tests anweisen
kann in den betrieben aber wir brauchen
auch die instrumente die zur kontakt
begrenzung so kontakt reduzierung
notwendig sind die wissenschaftler sagen
ganz deutlich in regionen wie schleswig
holstein mit der hohen impfquote 20
prozent kontakt reduzierung in sachsen
60 prozent kontakt reduzierung wenn wir
das nicht liefern können werden wir in
einer humanitären katastrophe enden die
dinge sind alle sichtbar und deswegen
geht es nicht darum was man sich
politisch und ausgedacht hat und wie man
politisch handelt hier geht es um ein
virus und den kann man nicht durch
politische spielchen bekämpfen sondern
nur durch medizin und durch wissenschaft
denn die frage noch mal zu ihnen herr
kretschmann auch sie haben schon von
history gesprochen und dann wieder wir
haben das virus nicht ernst genommen
auch da gab es in ihren äußerungen
gegenüber ihren landsleuten ja im
letzten jahr schon alles wie sehr
schreiben sie sich auch diese situation
zu ja das ist auch einer der fehler dass
wir immer nur aus der vergangenheit
sehen aber dass wir uns was wir heute
haben diese delta variante hat eine ganz
andere kraft und wucht wir können sie
mit der des vergangenen jahres überhaupt
nicht vergleichen wissenschaftler sagen
es ist wie als wenn sie die ursprungs
variante mit der geschwindigkeit eines
menschen wie er läuft vergleicht mit der
delta variante mit einem rennwagen das
sind die dimensionen die dazwischen
liegen
das ist auch das was wir heute sehen und
deswegen sind die instrumente die wir im
vergangenen jahr hatten nicht
ausreichend für das was jetzt vor uns
liegt wir brauchen mehr eine geräte wie
die neue position auch vorgesehen das
sind auch absolut richtig mehr testen
mehr möglichkeiten in den betrieben die
abfrage das sind alles gute dinge die
muss man tun aber andere müssen eben
noch hinzu treten wir sind verbunden in
düsseldorf mit helga rübsamen chef auch
sie sehr herzlich willkommen in dieser
sendung virologin chemikerinnen
managerin und für die leopoldina
arbeiten und in ihr verrückt sein chef
die wissenschaftler waren sich ziemlich
einig dass wenn wir es nicht schaffen
genug menschen zu impfen dass wir dann
im herbst und winter ein echtes problem
gekommen warum ist das wieder von der
politik unterschätzt worden
gut ich kann da relativ wenig zur
politik sagen warum die dinge
unterschätzt aber es ist absolut richtig
dass wir diese welle haben kommen sehen
wir sind sehenden auges da rein gelaufen
ich würde aber gerne mal ein ganz ganz
anderen aspekt bringen der in meinen
augen noch viel zu wenig beachtet wurde
denn zweig wirklich was bringt und zwar
wenn sie es nach israel gucken und die
ganze entwicklung sehen dann kann man
davon sehr viel lernen ist ja sehr früh
angefangen zu impfen ein wahnsinn im
frühling durch haben ihren freedom day
gefeiert unter der regierung netanjahu
dann kam aber die delta variante und in
kürzester zeit hat israel wieder die
krankenhäuser voll hatte wieder eine
ganze menge
infizierte und im september waren sie
dann schon bei einer 7 tages incidents
von 800 und dann hat der staat noch mal
ganz massiv die impfung nach oben
gefahren die haben 80 prozent der
älteren durchgeimpft und bei 43 prozent
das gesamt genau gerechnet mit dem mit
diesem booster impfungen und
das virus ging runter sie können jetzt
täglich zu gucken wie die das virus
zahlen sinken was sie aber außerdem
gemacht haben das ist glaube ich eine
lehre für uns sie haben gesagt wenn
jemand zweimal geimpft ist und die
impfung liegt länger die zweite republik
länger als sechs monate zurück betrachte
ich ihnen den ungeimpften das heißt wer
sich drittes mal nicht impfen lässt wer
das verpasst der darf dann eben einfach
nicht mehr ins kino oder ins restaurant
er kann sich frei testen lassen damals
war den test selbst bezahlen also anders
als wir sagen wir wollen dass jeder den
test frei bekommt und nichts zahlen muss
israel versucht damit ein bisschen druck
ausüben dass man eben den test selbst
bezahlt und auch die masken pflicht im
innenraum gilt ganz streng und wird über
wird überprüft und ferner auch strafen
die sind sehr hoch wenn zum beispiel ein
restaurantbesitzer diese ganzen regeln
missachtet also wir denken immer zweig
ist gut aber weil das virus ist und weil
die
qualität was infektion betrifft
innerhalb von sechs monaten erheblich
nachlässt zwar nicht unbedingt die für
die der schutz des einzelnen vor der
erkrankung aber wie gesagt diese leute
können sich anstecken die können das
virus übertragen das passiert ja genau
ist wenn man sich eben nur auf zweig
verlässt zu wenig also erklärt da müssen
wir auch sagen zweimal geimpft und ein
drittes mal hinterher dann ist alles wie
früher oder wir sagen zweimal geimpft
plus testen kann man zumindest
überprüfen wer es hat ja wir hatten in
unserer letzten sendungen auch eine
schalte nach israel nach tel aviv und
haben uns das erklären lassen natürlich
ist das jetzt genau das was man tun muss
entweder also maximal boostern und
natürlich diese berühmte im pflücke
schließen in den berichten des rkv rück
samen chef war im juni schon mit
modellierungen gezeichnet was passiert
wenn wir nicht eine bestimmte zahl an
impfungen erreichen klar war es aber im
grunde genommen schon früher dass wir
wenn wir im pflücken nicht schließen in
eine solche situation kommen richtig
klar und klar ist eben auch wenn wir die
2g als sicher ansehen heute sechs monate
später dass er da auch ein fehler machen
jetzt hinzu kommen könnte und was die
politik auch vorantreiben könnte es gibt
hier inzwischen zwei pillen gegen korona
beides von amerikanischen unternehmen
das eine ist das motto pierer wir das
andere heißt praxis mit monotherapie ist
inzwischen in uk großbritannien
zugelassen also die haben auch schon
250.000 packungen gekauft für die
bevölkerung das könnte ich ja auch
geschehen und diese diese medikamente da
hat man in klinischen studien sehr
eindeutig zeigen können das erste senkt
die zahl der kranken und die zahl der
todesfälle und 50 prozent das zweite
sogar zwischen 80 und 90 prozent warum
tut man das nicht das wäre also eine
maßnahme mit wo sie genau diese lücke
jetzt bei uns schließen könnte
gesetzesänderung zu diskutieren das was
kann ich wiederum nicht nachvollziehen
so da sind zwei ganz klare fragen an die
politik fragen wir zuerst in dresden
herr kretschmer haben sie von diesen
beiden medikamenten schon gehört und
würden sie auch sagen die müssen zügig
nach deutschland ja das wird ja auch
passieren das ist ja selbstverständlich
stimme übrigens zu 2g ist sich die
lösung aller probleme auf der anderen
seite ist auch ganz klar wir müssen sehr
hart an dem bleiben was medizinisch
geboten ist und wenn wir sehen dass vor
allen dingen diejenigen die nicht
geimpft sind jetzt auch die treiber der
pandemie sind dass die in den
krankenhäusern liegen ist es glaube ich
auch richtig die unter einem besonderen
schutz zu nehmen weitere dinge müssen
dazu kommen ich finde die vorschläge die
jetzt gemacht worden sind absolut
richtig auch dass die frage angeht wenn
man nach einer gewissen zeit keine
booster impfung hat verfällt man der der
impfschutz und dann auch dieses
zertifikat das sind alles kluge
vorschläge die ganz schnell jetzt
umgesetzt werden müssen und wir sind
noch mal herr reitz bei dem was sie
vorhin sagten wir konnten vor drei
wochen den spanier tatsächlich wirklich
noch bei der inhaltlichen begründung für
diese lage zu hören schauen wir noch mal
die hygienische lage der ausnahmezustand
vom bundestag festgestellt der kann aus
meiner sicht beendet werden weil vier
von fünf erwachsene geimpft sind für das
robert koch institut ist klar geimpfte
haben ein moderates risiko
nochmal vier von fünf sind geimpftes rk
ii sagte dass tatsächlich bei den
geimpften ein moderates risiko ist
schwer zu erkranken und schwer zu
erkranken überhaupt weil geben was hat
es ausgelöst dass wir solche botschaften
zwischendurch gehört haben und im
wahlkampf übrigens gar nichts gehört
haben ja wo war da die politik man hat
natürlich also man hat natürlich sie
stellt viele fragen ja mal hat man
natürlich gehofft dass die impfung an
das erledigt
das haben alle gehofft dass war
fraktions und parteivorsitz übergreifend
so um dann hat man aber festgestellt die
zahlen gehen hoch und jens spahn hat
mehrfach seine meinung geändert übrigens
zu anderen themen auch
und das ist mir auch passieren so und
man muss sagen die fdp hat immer schon
gesagt dass sie also jetzt in den
letzten monaten dass sie aus dieser
pandemischen lage raus will da ist sie
sich also treu geblieben deswegen kann
man den kann vorwurf machen sie haben
sozusagen wort gehalten haben geliefert
mit mit hilfe von herrn scholz weil der
eben politisch jetzt gerade eine neue
regierung verhandelt und eine koalition
zusammenbringen will und guten grund sei
der fdp im übrigen auch den grünen in
dieser frage
entgegen zu kommen und deswegen ist das
so gekommen wie es gekommen ist auch das
angemessen ist es ja die ganz andere
frage die nachrichten sind furchtbar und
wir hören jetzt von maßnahmen die eine
völlig andere richtung gehen wieder von
kontakt beschränkungen und wider von lok
downs jetzt not schutzschalter heißen
sollen
aber die richtung was hinter dieser
gruppe vorgeschlagen und
so und das ist geschichte wir gehen
immer nimmt die arme hoch und
noch mehr sondern es für sie vorstellbar
ist eine situation kostbar herr kubicki
in der alters was sie gesagt haben wir
möchten keine schließungen mehr nicht
mehr in ganzen branche wir wollen
kontakt beschränkungen nicht mehr wollen
ausgangssperren nicht mehr wo sie diese
milden maßnahmen nicht ausreichen werden
wenn man jetzt ja das argument von herrn
kretschmann formulierte kritik an der
kriegs mal formuliert bedauerlicherweise
immer argumente die darauf hinweisen
dass ist ein fundamental versagen seiner
partei und der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion je mehr das war sie
vorgeschlagen und auch die die
konkretisierung beispiel so also sind ja
im jetzigen infektionsschutz das gar
nicht enthalten und das problem ist ich
erwarte dann das die union wenn sie
jetzt mit solchen wunderbaren
vorschlägen kommt doch im parlament mal
einen entsprechenden antrag stellt also
sich hinzustellen und zu sagen das was
er das macht ist falsch hätten wir
nichts gemacht wären 25 helfen alles
ausgenommen hände und das ist das
problem
ich wollte nichts sagen noch nicht sie
sagen ja sogar das ende voraus am 19.3
des nächsten jahres wissen wollte woher
wissen sie dass das ende juni zu ende
ist ja wie immer wir befristen alle
diese maßnahmen immer bis zu bestimmten
zeitpunkten und selbstverständlich wird
der deutsche bundestag soll die
situation wirklich kritisch werden
reagieren und schneller als die mpk da
sie immer kann wir sind in der lage
innerhalb von 48 stunden gesetzliche
regelungen zu schaffen die das diaz
verändern aber doch nicht auf vorrat und
auf jeden fall nicht ohne
parlamentarische beteiligung das ist
doch das entscheidende den leuten ist
mittlerweile übrigens auch die hutschnur
geplatzt überlegen sie sich mal die
ministerpräsident kanzlerin kommen auf
die glorreiche denen nachts eine oster
ruhe auszurufen sie wollen mit der frage
zu beschäftigen ob das rechtlich
überhaupt geht weil ich am nächsten tag
entschuldige mich eine bundesregierung
dieser nächsten moment schuldigen muss
weil sie feststellt dass wir wollen geht
rechtlich gar nicht ich erwarte eine
vernünftige arbeit in halle 5 die
vernünftigen gehen zweiradfahrer
wertschätzung nicht der
gesundheitsminister des landes schleswig
holstein im august bereits angefangene
fdp das gibt er hat mit fdp nichts zu
tun sondern wenn klar ist dass wussten
wir seit juli das wir dass wir in eine
sprechen herausforderung im herbst
bekommen dann muss man gegensteuern im
august die acht über 80 jahren
angeschrieben die sind jetzt nahezu
durchgepustet bei uns wir haben jetzt
die über 70-jährigen die demnächst durch
bewusst sind wir haben fragen sie mal
wie das in sachsen und den bayern aus
als hätten sie genauso machen können wir
haben interessanterweise dagegen
widerspruch da gehört auch nicht reicher
bürger dagegen die freidemokraten sich
gewandt wir haben gesagt ihr könnt doch
nicht jetzt wenn ihr glaubt dass wir
mehr leute impfen müssen und auch mit
dem muster in form machen müssen könnte
die fünf zentren zu schaffen die ärzte
noch alleine gar nicht die masse an
notwendige impfungen in kurzer zeit auf
den weg zu bringen wir reden über 16
millionen nicht geimpft und wir reden
über sagen wir mal 30 millionen menschen
sind muss dann 30 million menschen die
gebucht werden müssen wissen sie wie
lange das dauert das auch über die
hausärzte die betriebsärzte und ohne
impfzentren auf die strecke zu bringen
da sind wir im januar nächsten jahres
und das ist der fehler dass diese
regiert hier abgewählte regierung sich
darauf wissend nicht vorbereitet frage
natürlich nochmal an herrn kretschmer
warum sind diese impfzentren geschlossen
worden und wie schnell kriegen sie die
jetzt wieder geöffnet ich glaube ein
zentrales ist wieder offen bei ihnen
ja gut das ist ja ein hin und her
gespielt jetzt viele und man sich daran
das ist keine ernsthafte diskussionen
gibt es über die wirkliche und lösung
dieser schwierigen frage die auf uns
zukommen
schleswig holstein ist ein bisschen
kleiner als der freistaat sachsen oder
als bayern und natürlich wird hier in
größenordnung auch gewusst hat und die
leute werden angesprochen wir haben
mobile impft teams die kapazität wird
jetzt mehr als verdoppelte der nächsten
zeit wir haben bei den ärzten diese
riesigen probleme dass sie 14 tage
vorher den impfstoff bestellen mussten
jetzt in diesen stunden ist das wieder
verändert worden da gibt es ganz viele
dinge die im hintergrund laufen die auch
mit der industrie zu tun haben die damit
zu tun haben dass in der vergangenheit
die die bereitschaft zum impfen zu sehr
zurück gegangen ist dass die empfehlung
der ständigen impfkommission erst vor
kurzem passiert ist was das bewusstsein
angeht aber wissen sie was mich am
meisten ärgert ist wenn man sieht wie
die situation sich zuspitzt und dann
solche banalen ausreden und zuweisungen
falle von problemen als wir müssen uns
doch jetzt mit der sache beschäftigen
und das war deutsche politik zum thema
corona zumindest in den ersten monaten
wie lösen wir das problem das hat uns
halten sie es diese zeit gebracht dieses
ziel sollte man jetzt nicht verlieren
sondern wirklich vernünftig miteinander
zusammenarbeit ich bin dazu bereit wir
treffen diese entscheidungen auch aber
ich finde diese schuldzuweisungen völlig
unangemessen sie helfen überhaupt nicht
lösen überhaupt kein problem sie
verunsichern die bevölkerung das robert
koch institut bringt eine mahnung nach
der anderen in den vergangenen monaten
war es so dass die politik darauf
reagiert hat die ministerpräsidenten
gemeinsam mit der bundesregierung das
hat auch die bevölkerung
sensibilisiert und eine richtung gegeben
jetzt fehlt das komplett und ich finde
das ist ein großes manko in der
aktuellen politik waren also nächste
woche soll es nun diese dieses treffen
mit den ministerpräsidenten
wiedergeben und mit der spitze der
regierung also offensichtlich frau
merkel und vielleicht auch olaf scholz
mehr gehen mal davon aus waren diese mpk
treffen denn so von effizienz dass sie
sagen das ist jetzt unbedingt das was
uns wieder hilft ja es hat uns durch
diese krise gebracht und bis zum märz
diesen jahres das erste mal politisch
entschieden worden ist nicht anhand
dessen was mediziner und wissenschaftler
gesagt hat hat uns das sehr gut durch
die zeit getragen dritte lockdown wäre
vermeidbar gewesen hätte man am vierten
märz nicht politisch entschieden dass
die korona pandemie beendet ist und
jetzt passiert das gleiche das aufheben
der pandemischen lage in dieser zeit war
doch in der bevölkerung
das signal es ist alles nicht so schlimm
das hat uns unglaublich viel schaden
bereitet jetzt sind wir wieder in einem
anderen modus aber sie sehen ja wir
haben höchstzahlen von krone infektionen
die so dramatisch sind wir sind weit
über dem was ich tat begangen hat der
schuldige sei deswegen sie haben auch
schon über volle kliniken in sachsen zu
beklagen herr kretschmar und christian
drosten sagt das wird nicht nur in
sachsen so sein dass sagen sie auf
gerader und er denkt zweig wird nicht
reichen darüber haben wir eben schon
diskutiert es müsse auch wieder kontakt
beschränkungen geben halten sie denn den
lockdown für ausgeschlossen
ich habe ihn vor hin gerade gesagt
medizinisch notwendig aus für diese
pandemie ist eine kontakt reduzierung in
den regionen mit einer hohen imk wurde
von 20 prozent in sachsen um 60 prozent
deswegen reicht zweig nicht das ist
jetzt der erste schritt wir gehen diesen
weg das waren das erste bundesland es
gab eine riesige aufregung markus söder
hat absolut recht wenn wir das zum
standard für ganz deutschland machen
dann müssen weitere instrumente dazu
folgen das kann das impfen das kann die
das testen seien in den betrieben muss
es auch sein und es muss auch die
kontakt beschränkung seien die jetzt in
sachsen schon jetzt an der überlastung
die in der überlastung stufe noch einmal
mehr wird jetzt zu beginn der kommenden
woche und ein lockdown kann man nicht
ausschließen was machen sie wenn die
krankenhäuser nicht mehr können dann
muss es dieses instrument geben um noch
schlimmeres zu verhindern wir können
doch nicht sehenden auges in bilder wie
bergamo in situation kommen wollen
sie schließen natürlich nicht nur den
doktoren aus sondern sie gehen auch
davon aus dass wir diese einschränkungen
bundesweite kontakt einschränkungen
nicht brauchen und sie glauben auch
nicht dass man das noch mal kassieren
muss mich wirst du momentan nicht also
zunächst einmal wundere ich mich darüber
dass herr söder und der kretzschmar
jetzt auch die potenziellen koalitionäre
für einen gesetzentwurf bereits
kritisieren und zwar ziemlich massiv
will muss auch mit fake news der noch
gar nicht als gesetz vorliegt noch nicht
vollständig sagen wir sind in einem
gesetzgebungsverfahren wir haben montag
eine anhörung daraus werden
logischerweise konsequenzen ich kann
mich daran erinnern dass die
bundesregierung unter führung von angela
merkel erklärt hat einen weiteren
lockdown wird es nicht geben abgesehen
davon dass er auch nur schwer zu
begründen wäre
uns auch noch andere fragen stellen wir
haben jetzt 5000 intensivbetten weniger
als es nun erklären warum sie müssen
wirklich erklären warum in dieser
lockten schwer zu gewinnen ist weil herr
kretschmann gerade gesagt es kommt zu
einer das hat er nicht gesagt weil dort
nicht gesagt aber er darf ja auch gerne
einen wir wieder richtig investieren
geld in sachsen ein zu machen das tor
ist solange wir keine so lange wir keine
evidenz dafür haben dass er tatsächlich
zur pandemie geschehen und zu bekämpfen
wir gehen dennoch möglich machen für die
länder als maß aber ich bin
interessanterweise
jurist und verpflichtet als
parlamentarier nichts zu machen dass sie
für rechtswidrig halte das können sie
von mir auch nicht erwarten das was da
dort vorgelegt werden das halte ich für
rechtswidrig also wenn ich mich daran
nicht beteiligen jetzt alle anderen ihre
auffassung kam können das gerne äußern
wie ich meine meinung dass der anblick
ist rechtswidrig was ist rechtswidrig
ausgangssperren sind rechtswidrig
flächendeckend mehrfach reduziert worden
auch ein flächendeckender lockdown wäre
rechtswidrig weil sie dort massiv in die
wirtschaftliche aus bildungsfreiheit
eingreifen wenn sie ganze branchen
schließen weil sie wir haben bis
irgendein vergangen wir haben wir im
vergangenen jahr im ersten erst zum
ersten november die gastronomie
geschlossenen die hotellerie und fiel im
kulturbereich wir haben gemerkt dass das
ganze nicht reicht zum 14 dezember bzw
16 dezember ist in deutschland ein
lockdown verfügt worden ab diesem
zeitpunkt gegen die zahlen massiv nach
unten das war der brecher dieser welle
im dezember des vergangenen jahres und
deswegen noch einmal niemand will einen
lock down alles was wir tun muss dazu
dienen dass das nicht passiert dazu ist
ein schnelles konsequentes handeln oder
ich möchte auch keinen lockdown aber ich
muss ihnen ich kann ihn nicht
ausschließen wenn die situation
eskaliert und ich habe die ersten
krankenhäuser die in größter sorge sind
und das ist ja auch vollkommen klar wenn
sie instanzen von 1000 haben wer ein
bisschen offen durch die welt geht und
sich die deutschlandkarte anschaut wie
sie sich von tag zu tag immer weiter
einfärbt der kann doch nicht einfach
dasitzen und sagen das geht alles nicht
und es ist auch falsch dass das
rechtswidrig wäre es gibt
ausgangssperren die von gerichten
aufgehoben worden sind und es gibt
gerichte die das als richtig empfunden
habe es halt immer mit der aktuellen
situation zu tun und jetzt ist es doch
kein argument zu sagen wenn wir uns
geirrt haben machen wir innerhalb von 48
stunden ein neues gesetz hier geht es
darum dass wir gemeinsam der bevölkerung
gegenüber treten und sagen diese vierte
welle ist härter ist schwieriger ist
gefährlicher als das was wir erlebt
haben bitte seien sie gemeinsam
vorsichtig bitte tun sie das was das
robert-koch-institut sagt vermeiden sie
veranstaltungen gehen sie nicht zur
veranstaltung bleiben sie zu hause
vermeiden sie kontakte diese ansprache
und zwar von einer breiten politischen
öffentlichkeit und gesellschaftliche
notwendigkeit ist das was in dieser
phase notwendig ist wir fragen noch mal
annika graf geht frau kraft die es ist
ja so dass in bayern die richter die
ausgangs beschränkungen die es da
gegeben hat nachträglich für
rechtswidrig erklärt haben es gibt auch
klagen etliche klagen vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht zur bundes
notbremse ist es damit nicht wir sogar
ganz klug in der ampelkoalition zu
überlegen dass man mit den
einschränkungen nicht so weit gehen
möchte die man den bürgern zugemutet in
einer situation in der eben hoffentlich
bald zwei drittel der menschen hier
müsste ja in bezug auf bestimmte
maßnahmen würde ich das genauso sehen
also diese harten ausgangssperren wie
sie zum beispiel in bayern verhängt
worden sind in der tat die wurden vom
verwaltungsgerichtshof jetzt in der
hauptsache entscheidung für rechtswidrig
erklärt wobei man schon sagen muss also
da wurde jetzt nicht gesagt immer für
alle zeit gilt das sondern es wurde ihm
gesagt damals in der welle mit dem
damaligen fahren das waren 7000 da war
das so wie das beurteilt würde jetzt
wenn wirklich wir wieder triage
situationen haben in den
intensivstationen das weiß man nicht
möglicherweise würde man das auch anders
sehen also so klar sind die
gerichtsurteile leider nicht aber also
beispielsweise branchenweite schließung
von bestimmten sehr infektiös
bereichen beispielsweise bordelle oder
saunen also da hat eigentlich kein
gericht gesagt in diesen hochphasen der
pandemie dass das irgendwie unzulässig
ist sondern ich
ja aber erst ja aber erst als in vielen
runtergingen das wurde immer sehr genau
abgestimmt auf die jeweilige lager und
in den hochphasen haben sie ganz viele
gerichte gesagt das ist in ordnung und
erst als es abgeklungen ist und man
lockerungsmaßnahmen erlassen hat da hat
man gesagt wegen des
gleichheitsgrundsatzes muss man dann das
auch für bordelle anordnen auch für
sauna wiewohl das war auch richtig
anzusprechen gilt das war im februar
nicht einmal aussprechen
also man muss sehr genau hingucken was
ist die situation vor ort was ist die
gesamt gesetzeslage wurde hinreichend
begründet und es ist nicht so dass
gerichte pauschal gesagt hätten das ist
grundsätzlich unzulässig in deutschland
solche entscheidungen hat es nicht
gegeben das ist einfach schlicht falsch
und das sind fähig ist und im übrigen
ich finde das irgendwie auch ein
bisschen seltsam dass wir hier die ganze
darüber diskutieren wer ist eigentlich
schuld die cdu die fdp ehrlich gesagt
ich finde das ist überhaupt nicht
relevant ist sterben täglich menschen
und das ziel muss doch sein jetzt
vernünftige rechtsgrundlagen zu schaffen
und da finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen
schwachen sie sagen ja aber die anderen
sind schuld wenn sie mal in die
rechtsgrundlagen reichen jetzt nicht aus
dann schaffen sie doch die haben doch
jetzt in der ampelkoalition im bundestag
eine mehrheit dann schaffen sie doch
rechtsgrundlagen die sie für angemessen
halte die schaffen wir ja gerade wenn
die union die ich bin nicht angemessen
hält erwarte ich einen vorschlag von ihr
was wir nicht mehr wollen ist das
massive grundriss einschritt
einschränkungen der von der mpk
beschlossen werden muss ist das
parlament ich sage wir kommen wie eine
sau das parlament beschließen wir
beschließen dass auch gerade ja also ein
maßnahmenkatalog der aber also wo sie
bisher noch nicht glaubhaft machen
können warum der denn jetzt die welle
brechen kann wenn sie sagen der vorwurf
ist die cdu hat keine maßnahmen
getroffen und deswegen sind jetzt in der
schlimmen situation wo wir sind und dann
ist ihre antwort darauf wir mildern die
maßnahmen ab das verstehe ich nicht wir
starten eine andere rechtsgrundlage und
jan eine mildere aber unter wasser aber
dann muss doch jemand der sagt das
reicht mir nicht aus wie beispielsweise
kretschmer reduziertes aus mir sieben
müssen noch einmal begründen warum das
aus raum ist ausreicht was sie da haben
weil ihr generalsekretär erklärt dass es
eine systemische überbelastung des
gesundheitswesens nicht mehr gibt das
wären wir ja auch seit einigen wochen
vor zwei wochen erst tatsächlich so aber
es gibt es gibt in einigen in einigen
regionen und in einigen kommunen eine
massive mehrbelastung das ist richtig
aber das system insgesamt keine aussage
von mir sondern von wissenschaftlichen
beirats ministerium heute im spiegel
online veröffentlicht es gibt
flächendeckende bundesweit kein engpass
so und wir müssen doch noch lange wird
es nicht bleiben wir sagen ja nun auch
alle also das wissen wir eben noch nicht
dass es sei ihm nicht also muss es
juristisch auch vorbereiten dann muss es
doch auch gesetzlich vorbereiten dass
wenn jetzt in essen also
intensivstationen wieder übervoll werden
wir können reinschreiben dass wenn eine
solche situation eintritt der deutsche
bundestag weitere maßnahme ist was wir
nicht wollen ist das noch einmal die
ministerpräsidenten ohne evidenz
einfachen entscheidungen treffen am
parlament vorbei was sie momentan können
wir wollen die jetzt im parlament das
recht so zurückgeben darüber zu
entscheiden welche massiven
grundrechtseingriff vorgenommen werden
müssen und welche nicht nach unserer
auffassung das aus was wir machen sollte
sich daran etwas ändern wird der
deutsche bundestag definitiv gehen wir
davon aus das ist kein parlamentarier da
der menschenleben aufs spiel setzen will
sollte dass er solche situationen kommen
die jetzt also drohend beschrieben
werden werden die entsprechend reagiert
gut so etwas entscheiden heute gesagt
fand ich jedenfalls eher der
fraktionsvorsitzende
von der spd herr scholz hat neben er was
man im parlament beobachten konnte den
kopf zusammen gesteckt hatte mit der
amtierenden bundeskanzlerin
hat er die aussage getroffen dass man
offen sein für veränderungen gemeint ist
in dem zusammenhang natürlich für sie
sagen verschärfungen und
das dass das wesen ist eines
gesetzgebungsprozess etwas vollkommen
richtig ist franz müntefering hat mal
gesagt kein gesetz kommt also wieder
raus aus dem parlament ließ reingegangen
ist das ist auch so dass herr kubicki
hat ja auch eine anspielung darauf
gemacht ich rechne damit dass dieses
gesetzesvorhaben wo wir heute die im
parlament die eröffnungsveranstaltung
hatten in der nächsten woche noch mal
nach den anhörungen die es ja geben wird
verschärft wird es ging auch es war ein
politischer prozess außer sicht von olaf
scholz dafür zu sorgen dass man einen
gesetzentwurf im bundestag einbringen
bevor die ministerpräsidenten konferenz
tagt um ein signal zu setzen wir holen
den prozess zurück ins parlament und
schieben ihnen weg von den länderchefs
und von ihm deshalb habe der bundesrat
muss zustimmen also aircraft mal jede
chance
der bundesrat ist sechs wochen schon
soll ja am freitag dann schon geschehen
locker und nie wieder impfpflicht nie
wieder diese zwei verlässliche aussage
also der der kann niemand zurzeit
ausschließen die mehrere nicht alle
sagen aber nie alles habe sondern
mehrere auf deren wort wir hören die
haben schon gesagt ist muss wir müssen
offen sein für lokale lockt 1 also das
ist eine so genannten flächen deckenden
lockdown gibt dass erstens will das
niemand und dann muss man auch nicht
unbedingt glauben dass aber in lokalen
ebenen die wie etwa in landkreisen in
bayern wo die inzidenz mittlerweile auf
1100 ist dass man da andere maßnahmen
trifft wie wie anderswo das ist
irgendwie auffällig fragen
und sie sagen ja man kann einzelne
schulen schließen das stimmt auch aber
also im mittleren landkreis stilllegen
nicht auf grundlage dessen was sie
vorgelegt haben vielleicht wollen sie
das ja noch alles ändern
das infektionsschutzgesetz ist nein weil
sie es auf 28 stützen notwendige
maßnahme das ist dann aber mit der
wesentlichkeit theorie nicht mehr so gut
vereinbar da haben sie auch also
zumindest fdp fraktion in ihrer
oppositionsarbeit im letzten jahr immer
was ganz anderes gesagt als damals 28
jahre sat 1 eingeführt wurde haben sie
gesagt wir brauchen ganz klare regeln
für so grundrechts beschränkende
maßnahmen
klar sind wir klare kriterien sind klare
tatbestandsvoraussetzungen klar
rechtsfolgen also da muss man sich dann
irgendwie auch mal entscheiden
ob man eine schule schließen darf oder
nicht unglücklich gegen die burmesische
kommen sie gar nicht daran vorbei dass
reinzuschreiben in den gesetzentwurf das
können sie dann nicht einfach so mal
beschließen das geht eigentlich gar
nicht arbeiten gesetzt ist das wesen
eines gesetzes verfahrens ist mir das
haben sie in zwei tagen hin auch einfach
dass es in zwei tagen kein
chef wir sind noch einmal bei der
wissenschaftlerin auch an sie die frage
wird die politik das wieder kassieren
müssen nie wieder ein lock down und nie
eine schlecht also ich glaube schon dass
die gefahr besteht und ich glaube auch
nicht dass das parlament ewig zeit hat
jetzt sich jetzt zu streifen über eine
gesetzgebung wir müssen jetzt handeln
und zwar sehr schnell und nebenbei will
ich nur darauf hinweisen dass es sehr
klare daten gibt die zum beispiel zeigen
dass ein lockdown was bringt das eine
ausgangssperre war es bringt da gibt es
eine studie von der oxford university
die europaweit diese daten gesammelt hat
und eine metaanalyse gemacht hat und da
kann man rein gucken und kann kann
wirklich sehen welche maßnahme bringt
was also was der kubicki sagt das wäre
gar nicht bekannt ob eine maßnahme was
bringt das stimmt so nicht
lassen sie mich mal bitte ausreden da
kann nur ist interessanterweise auch aus
der schulschließung gar nicht so viel
brachten weil zu dem zeitpunkt eben die
kinder überwiegend schon mit masken usw
ausgestattet waren und man zu testen
begonnen hatte wir sind bei der gleichen
frage oder ähnlichen frage an sie frau
rübsamen chef nachdem der der
systemischen überlastung des und des
gesundheitssystems da sagt er die fdp
die seien nicht gegeben glauben sie auch
dass ist zu kassieren weil wir längst
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
haben also nach allem was ich höre
stehen mir sehr kurz davor also die die
charité hat schon gesagt in einer woche
geht es nicht mehr und es gibt einige
krankenhäuser die sagen noch ein paar
wochen dann müssen wir auch wieder eine
trial stecken also ich glaube und ich
meine das virus stoppten nicht eine
woche lang und wartet bis die
parlamentarier daran gesetz gemacht
haben ich glaube wir immer verantwortung
hat muss jetzt handeln und so schnell
wie möglich und ich sage es nochmal wir
brauchen dringend diese diese neuen
medikamente damit kann man also muss es
vielleicht nochmal erklären das ist ein
billiger sind medikamente die sie
bekommen wenn sie frisch infiziert sind
in den ersten tagen das sind tabletten
die man zu hause in quarantäne nehmen
kann und die senken das virus und
bedeuten damit dass eben die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie erkranken
viel geringer ist und weil das virus
gesenkt das sind sie auch nicht so
ansteckend für ihre für ihre umgebung
das heißt sie denken auch gleichzeitig
die übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit und
diese medikamente wirklich gezielt
einzusetzen und so schnell wie möglich
nach deutschland zu holen das wäre in
meinen augen dringend erforderlich dass
und das war ja unsere leopoldine
stellungnahme gewesen dass eben auch die
gesamte medikamentenforschung gegen
korona in deutschland auf ganz andere
füße stellen müssen das war auch eine
förderung und wir haben das jetzt zum
zweiten mal vernommen und nicht nur wir
sondern hoffentlich eine menge menschen
noch eine ganz blöde frage kann das
zurverfügungstellen solcher wirksamen
medikamente kamen chef im verweigerer
oder skeptiker dann irgendwie davon
abhalten sich impfen zu lassen weil die
sagen na ja also dann warte ich halt bis
die medikamente hier sind es gibt ja
welche also das will ich nicht
ausschließen dass manche leute so denken
auf der anderen seite soll man sich auch
nichts vormachen die impfung allein auch
wenn 85 prozent erreicht hat wie zum
beispiel dänemark jetzt da waren ja sehr
stolz haben auch wieder ihren frieden
freedom day ausgerufen und jetzt sieben
an wie schön das virus allmählich hoch
maschine den dänemark das heißt also auf
85 prozent durch impfung reicht nicht
wir müssen uns mit dem gedanken vertraut
machen dass wir mehr als ein instrument
haben müssen und die eben gemeinsam dann
nutzen ich begrüße annemarie annemarie
fabiano stellvertretende präsidentin des
deutschen pflegerates und examinierte
altenpflegerin profis gutes wie sie bei
uns haben es geht eben um diese
systemische überlastung des
gesundheitswesens stehen die schon kurz
vor dem kollaps wir sind quasi schon
mittendrin kann man sagen weil wir
sprechen ja nicht erst seit heute über
ein pflegenotstand und über einen
kollaps im gesundheitssystem sondern das
tun wir ja eigentlich schon seit 50
jahren und das haben wir auch als
ortschaftsrat jetzt im prinzip seit 1998
mehr genau und das heißt jetzt kommt zu
diesen ganzen pflegenotstand den wir
seit jahrzehnten beklagen noch eine
pandemie dazu insofern sind wir mitten
im kollaps diese pandemie gibt es nun
seit anderthalb jahren ausgerechnet in
diesem zweiten winter fehlen betten und
es fehlt personal
und es gibt eine wachsende zahl von
menschen was glauben sie wann müssen sie
auch den notstand oder die im
katastrophenfall ausrufen also
tatsächlich gibt es ja auch betten
sperrungen die hatten wir auch schon vor
corona wir haben in den
pflegeeinrichtungen also nicht nur in
den krankenhäusern sondern auch in den
pflegeheimen
belegung stopps auch auferlegt bekommen
von den heimaufsichten weil wir wussten
wenn jetzt eben noch zugänge reinkommen
also wenn wir zum beispiel jetzt
bewohnerinnen aufnehmen aus den
krankenhäusern die zum beispiel und eine
kurze zeit im krankenhaus gelegen haben
oder wir nehmen tatsächlich neuzugänge
auf das heißt also es gibt eine
neuaufnahme aus einem ambulanten
pflegedienst
dann wissen wir unter umständen tragen
wir das virus in diese einrichtungen
hinein und insofern müssen wir
tatsächlich immer wieder schauen über
welche schließung die hier tatsächlich
nachdenken müssen und natürlich wissen
sie nicht nur sondern haben auch
verfolgt das ist eine ganz große
diskussion um die impfpflicht für
pflegerinnen und pflegern in altenheimen
gibt eben weil wieder vermehrt auch
menschen sterben gerade in
alteneinrichtungen wir schauen uns das
noch mal an